In assessing past school reforms, it's
all too easy to find glossy PR or ad
hominem critiques. Much harder to find
are analyses that tease out practical
lessons. In our new book, we identify
two. One: It's easy to forget that
political timelines are different than
educational ones. Elections breed a sense
of urgency among policymakers, and a
desire for rapid visible change, as with
President Obama's Race to the Top. Yet,
rebooting education policies, revamping
instructional materials, and changing
school cultures is a slower process. Two:
It is tough to course-correct
once high profile reforms pick up
momentum. By the time that ambitious
efforts like President Bush's No Child
Left Behind had disappointed and started
to fuel backlash, their champions were
too emotionally and politically invested
to readily alter course. There are
real constraints on how effective policy
will be when it comes to driving school
improvement. That suggests skepticism may
be warranted when eyeing the grand
educational promises of those vying for
office.
What do you think about the
school reforms of Presidents Bush and
Obama? Let us know in our poll. Also, let
us know what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds, and be
sure to like and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.